i have a story of when i sleep walked
once uh yeah the only time apparently
that i ever sleepwalked was when i was
little like i was like maybe four or
five years old right and apparently i
walked into my parents room
and i was asleep and my mom saw it she
was like what the [ __ ] are you doing and
then she realized that i was my my eyes
were closed and she was like oh [ __ ]
he's sleepwalking and i was saying
something to her but like it wasn't
really words it was kind of just like
woke up
and then the moment no the moment she
went wake up you dumb [ __ ] was when i
walked over to the corner of their room
and there was like a washing basket and
apparently i pulled my pants down into
it that's so weird okay okay
i have a worryingly similar story
not of me
[Laughter]
that's so crazy yeah so my little
brother had a sleepover
right
you know i was the one who was staying
awake a little longer than i should have
yeah i was playing on my game boy
whatever
and uh our house the floorboards
creak
really [ __ ] loudly yeah right and
obviously i've been in this house for
years so i could tell based off what
creek where someone was in the house and
where they were coming from like and and
what point they were on the stairs what
point they were like some kind of
[ __ ] daredevil [ __ ] except only for
my house
so
i heard someone who kept walking to the
middle of the like top of the stairs and
then back to my little brother's room
and then back to the stairs
and then back to the my little brother's
room like really slowly all right and
then after this happened twice i was
like what the [ __ ] so i went i watched
and he just walked
to the top of the stairs mumbled
something and then went back all right
what the [ __ ] and then you went to the
top of the stairs and then i was getting
worried because i'm like what if he just
like falls down yeah yeah that's
dangerous so he just starts walking down
the stairs really slowly right and this
is where i was like what do i do because
i didn't know what you're supposed to do
when someone's asleep walking yeah i've
heard loads of you've heard like myths
if you wake them up they can die yeah
you know so i was like
it seems like he's doing it okay i
didn't want to wake him up because what
if he wakes up
bro
you're awake
you know like i was like [ __ ] what do i
do so i'm i i see that he starts walking
down the stairs but like doing this
thing where he's going back and forth so
i'm like huh and i saw that like he was
like mumbling so i was like i think he's
sleepwalking yeah yeah so i go
to follow him and he's going down the
stairs really slowly and he gets to the
bottom of the stairs and so i go i go to
the one of the stairs and then he opens
the door to the living room and goes in
the living room this is like like the
[ __ ] like i don't know it's just like
horror film you stood there pitch black
because i didn't turn the lights off
it's so scary all i had was my game boy
sp advance to like light the thing
i didn't want to turn the lights on
because i didn't want to like joel yeah
yeah literally like i was like the
shitty like max brightness slider up
kind of like figure out what's going on
and i see him and he's just standing
there mumbling for like a good like 10
20 seconds and i'm freaking out because
i'm like what do i do like do i go and
like uh like wake my little brother up
and tell my parents because i don't know
what he's going to do so i was just
watching him making sure bear man i was
like 14 15 yeah
i didn't know the [ __ ] was going on and
so he's he's standing there in the
middle of this living room and then just
slowly starts like walking towards the
tv and then walking back to where he was
then he walks to the tv
and there's my video games all there
like in those one of those old 2000s
metal yeah actually
yeah
and then he just
starts pulling down his pants and then i
was like no no
like none of my games
and that's where i woke him up and i was
like no no no no no and then he woke up
and said well what what like that like
it was really weird how did you react to
him just like stan he acted like i was
the weirdo
i remember that i remember being like
what
he reacted like i was being weird like
because i was like stop stop like
shaking here you know i was exactly the
same as like my parents were like what
the [ __ ] are you doing and i'm like what
do you mean what the [ __ ] yeah yeah i
look down on my pants with that oh
okay that makes sense
but he was undoing now and that's where
i was like you're not pissing on my
[ __ ] ps2 oh no my pants were like
fully down my hand was on my dick and i
was like i was like ready to go on this
like so full basket of laundry so when
you work
oh so when you woke up did you
momentarily think like they were the
weirdos yeah okay see that's okay i was
like i was like
because i looked over and my mom was
like really worried looking like shaking
what's the problem
i didn't even really know this kid i
barely knew him so i was like we never
really like whenever i saw him it was
always awkward after that because he
just always remembered that time where
he woke up and i was like what the [ __ ]
when he always pissed on your games yeah
yeah based on my ps2 collection my wii u
my wii probably i don't know
yeah
do you ever get the point where like
there's something happening
in like in like um in the real world
where like you hear a sound or something
or like you need to go through the
toilets and it gets like integrated into
your dream for like a good while uh
i don't know if maybe but i probably
don't remember it like like the number
the most annoying thing for me is is
when i need to go to the toilet in my
dream because i don't immediately wake
up yeah when i go to the toilet when i
need to go to the toilet but like
luckily they're luckily my brain has a
disconnect between my body and my brain
because there has been several times
right where i've really really needed
there's been several times where i've
really really needed to piss and like in
my dream i don't know i'm dreaming but i
acknowledge the fact that i really
really need to piss right so yeah i've
had several like five-minute pisses in
my dreams and the and the feeling of the
piss just won't go away because
obviously i'm only pissing in my dream
and not in real life so i'm like i'm
like i'm like urinating and i'm like i
get so frustrated in my dream because no
matter how much i urinate the feeling of
needing needing to urinate never goes
away that's really weird
if i feel something if i if i piss
myself in my dream i'm pissing myself
yeah i'm just like that's that's how i'm
appreciating happening i almost [ __ ]
myself doing that
first of all
how can you replicate the feeling of
pissing so accurately in the dream yeah
to me without without actually pissing
yeah that's i can't replicate
feelings
i know that it's not accurate in the
dream
yeah yeah when i get when i get punched
in a dream it doesn't feel like a real
punch i can distinguish between that
yeah okay no like
for me it's so strong for me you must be
here with some like inception fifth
level dream yeah i'm not getting this
[ __ ] what are you experiencing i
i'm like in front of this urinal pissing
and i'm just like why is the feeling of
urinating not going away holy [ __ ] why
am i pissed is there an establishment of
the toilet as well before you start
you're like level 10 dreaming i'm a
level 2. this is insane yeah i don't
know and it's like i'm just like
at some point in the dream i just give
up on trying to get rid of this
urination i go on with a dream and then
i wake up and being like oh
that's why i needed to piss because it
was a dream and i need to piss in real
life and you hadn't pissed your pants no
i hadn't pissed my pants and then okay
and i have like the most satisfying piss
in my life because like yeah because for
me like every time i've had a dream when
i was a kid off going to the toilet i
have 100 pissed my pants
like i wake up and i'm just like i love
the confidence
and you know because of that one time i
will [ __ ] myself while i was asleep
here's the problem of uh growing up with
a bidet your whole life
and uh with this heated toilet seat is
the fact that it's just as a kid you're
just ingrained into your head of war oh
my butt is warm i'm sitting on a toilet
so in my dream
i'm on the toilet and i can feel that my
butt is warm right because it's a heated
toilet seat yeah so in my head i'm like
oh but warm i'm on a toilet this is
reality i'm actually going to take a
[ __ ]
and uh and so in my dream i i almost i
remember i almost start taking a [ __ ]
but then i was like something's not
right
why why can't i not [ __ ] right now
it's like i had the feeling that i
needed to [ __ ] yeah but i couldn't like
nothing was coming out and it wasn't
like a constipation type of thing it was
like literally like i know i need to
[ __ ] but nothing's coming out right and
then i woke up
and i was like oh
now i actually need a [ __ ] like i was
like prairie dogging
i was like oh god i was this close to
[ __ ] myself it's very strange
i'm in my dream i'm able to communicate
to like my non-dream brain being like oh
you need to piss oh no no no so i can
like i can stop the dream if i need to
pee like i can go oh there's been so
many instances where i know i'm in a
dream like i'm in a nightmare no it's
every time i'm in a nightmare i know i'm
in a nightmare i can't wake up i'm just
like go on wake up now please wake up
like i remember i remember one time i
was getting chased by this murderer or
someone like that it was like it was
like a scene out of uh what's that jack
nicholson film the shining yeah like it
was like the scene out of the shining
where i'm like getting chased by [ __ ]
jack nicholson or something yeah and i
knew i was in a nightmare yeah i just
didn't want to experience dying yeah
right in the dream because it still felt
real yeah of course and i'm just like
god wake up
nothing happens i'm like god i know
you're dreaming right now i know you're
[ __ ] dreaming [ __ ] murderer like
goes around the corner
start [ __ ] liking it and i'm like god
i know you're dreaming right now wake up
i know and my body refused to wake up
until i died and it was
i don't know why my brain is such an
[ __ ] that i can't wake myself up like
no you want to experience this
but i can only force like choose to wake
up when i need to pee or [ __ ] okay okay
oh i can't even do that i can like
in the dream i'll feel it and i know
that when i'm experiencing this dream
that i can feel this like a sensation
yeah and i know that i can i need to do
it yeah i won't stop the dream unless i
get to a point where it feels
uncomfortable and then i think i'll just
be like
you're on like 5g i'm on like dial up i
don't know like i'm just like i'm just
like you need a pierce you need a
piercer my brain's like all right hold
on i'm sending the most code right now
it's going to take a while weird man
that's too late
i'm sure people in the comments have
like even weirder drinks i'm i'm curious
now because i don't think i've ever seen
i've had such an in-depth talk about my
dreams
before i know i didn't even i didn't
even know it was not i thought it was
normal that you knew you were in a dream
no i i thought that was normal yeah
that's a lucid dream that's why they
call it the loser for you i thought
everyone had that because that's the
mainly the ones i have i've tried like
using methods to lucid dream because
there's like tutorials i'm like here's
how to lose a dream and one of them was
like cut a ping pong ball in half and
put them on your eye
people wanted lucid dreams yeah why
because they want to control their
dreams right they want to do whatever
they want their dream because most
people when they know they're in a dream
can control their dreams yeah like i
have no
like 99 times out of 100 i have no
control of my dreams
when i have loose control
so you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
just like your imagination just [ __ ]
do it normally do it awake
no i can't fly in my dreams i can't like
i can't like [ __ ]
like run a million miles an hour i can't
if my brain forces me to like experience
it yeah but i can't be like i can't just
be like all right tonight i'm gonna
dream about i don't know [ __ ] 100
[ __ ] like i can't i can't do that
doesn't that take away the excitement of
dreams if you choose what you're doing
no it just means like i said it's
literally to me it's like playing gta
with cheats on where you just where you
just like have fun like to me i just
it's just having like fun in this open
world
like at that point like people are npcs
when i realized that this is a dream and
i'm just like
i can do whatever i want i can fly to a
different city i can
yeah i can jack cars it's it's [ __ ]
great i have so much fun yeah weird yeah
i would i would be interested in
someone's psychoanalyzing our dreams
yeah honestly like because we all
obviously have three different
perspectives on how we dream and uh how
i like the experiences we have when we
dream it's so beautiful this has been a
very bizarre episode of trash tastes
dremologists out there as they call them
yeah dream all the time like a disney
job
yeah what are your experiences with
dreams
do you relate to us do you have
something entirely different let us know
because i uh joey or khan yeah
you're done